in our morning rounds the puzzling rise
in colorl cancer deaths in younger
adults a new study shows death rates for
white men and women under the age of 55
climb nearly 14% in a decade after years
of overall decline over the same period
deadly cases involving African-Americans
in the same age group went down CBS News
chief medical correspondent Dr John leuk
is a gastroenterologist John good
morning good morning blood so explain
this uh new study and what is causing
this number of cases to rise in white
males under 55 and women nobody knows
not Rebecca seagull who's the study
author not the American Cancer Society
but there's a really interesting Theory
so there's something called the
microbiome which includes the trillions
of bacteria that are in our guts one to
2,000 different species there's a war of
the world going on keeping themselves in
Balance well if it gets out of balance
there's a theory now in very interesting
research that certain species may
increase the risk of colon PPS and colon
cancer and maybe there's differences in
whites and blacks and other ethnicities
wow so as we mentioned the death rate
among younger African-Americans has gone
down and we still you're saying we don't
really real understand why race may be a
factor in this yeah and I want to make
sure because there's been some confusion
about this year toe yes there is been
some uh increase in mortality in whites
but still overall blacks are much more
likely to die and to get colon cancer
than whites why is that we don't know
but maybe actually a slightly or a
different biological disease so in
Blacks the cancers tend to be flatter on
the right side you tend to get them at
an earlier age and they tend to uh be
more deadly when they and more advanced
when they are uh discovered and that's
why the American College of
gastroenterology suggests screening
colonoscopy which in other people starts
at 50 or screening screening from other
means uh at 50 at to start at 45 in
African-American in
African-Americans and how often should
you do that if you're at no if you're at
average risk every 10 years if you had a
pup maybe every 5 years if it's a big
pup or a difficult pup to remove even
earlier than that does Diet make a
difference here you know diet probably
does make a difference so there's been
an increased risk uh in processed red
meats uh and in people who are obese
people who don't exercise in people who
have diabetes you want to be the right
weight there there are things you can do
but you know this is something that's in
all of our control in terms of the
screening so we we're looking at this
increase in younger people but if you
look at the people who are aged 50 to 54
only 44% of those people get screening
after that it goes up to the 60 over 60%
so the very first thing you should do
because people are thinking well should
with the guidelines move down because
more younger people are getting colon
cancer well first of all when you turn
50 get screen you know the best
screening method is the one you actually
do but it's such an uncomfortable
experience for so many people and
they're reluctant to sign up to do it
and now you're saying people should do
it at 45 that's well not the African
people but here's the thing uh the prep
has gotten easy
and you know people complain about the
prep and you know what it beats
chemotherapy point an easy thing to do
it's really an easy thing to do and when
you're under anesthesia um you know you
don't feel it it's really the prep that
people complain about Dr lauk good
advice thank you